para mostrarles qué tan poderosa es esta
aproximación de considerar varios
objetos como una misma masa veamos este
problema este problema no se ve sencillo
tenemos dos masas que están colgando de
una misma cuerda aquí tenemos una cuerda
de cuatro kilogramos que se encuentra en
una superficie inclinada esta masa tiene
atada una cuerda que pasa por una polea
y a su vez está atada a otra masa de 9
kilogramos que se encuentra colgando
verticalmente finalmente esta masa está
en un plano inclinado 30 grados y para
hacer más difícil este problema vamos a
decir que el coeficiente de fricción
cinética
que está entre esta masa de 4 kilogramos
y el plano inclinado es de 0.2 así que
aquí además tendremos fricción y este
puede ser un problema bastante difícil
de resolver de la forma difícil aunque
es posible resolverlo pero no nos va a
ser fácil pues vamos a tener varias
ecuaciones con varias incógnitas si
queremos aplicar la segunda ley de
newton en cada una de las masas pero
como estas masas tienen que acelerarse
con la misma proporción entonces podemos
tratarlas como si fueran un solo objeto
así que vamos a encontrar la aceleración
del sistema o al menos la magnitud de
esta aceleración esta masa de cuatro
kilogramos se va a acelerar hacia acá
con cierta magnitud y nuestra masa de
nueve kilogramos se va a acelerar
también hacia abajo cierta magnitud y
están unidas por una cuerda que no se va
a romper ni se va a estirar así que la
magnitud de estas aceleraciones va a ser
la misma y es por eso que podemos usar
este
este truco de tratar estos objetos como
si fueran uno solo y la aceleración o la
magnitud de la aceleración del sistema
depende solamente de las fuerzas
externas depende solamente de fuerzas
externas las cuales vamos a dividir
entre la masa total
si quisiéramos encontrar la aceleración
de esta masa de 4 kilogramos o al menos
su magnitud pues vamos a fijarnos vamos
a fijarnos en que si soltaremos estas
cajas esta caja de 9 kilogramos es más
masiva que la de 4 kilogramos por lo que
todo el sistema se comenzaría a mover en
esta dirección y a esta dirección vamos
a asignarle que sea positiva lo difícil
de tomar varios objetos como si fueran
uno solo es definir la dirección hacia
dónde se van a mover para algunas
personas a veces esto como que no es tan
sencillo de definir pero pensándolo un
poquito encontramos la respuesta y
normalmente cuando encontramos la
dirección hacia dónde se mueve el
sistema esa dirección va a tener signo
positivo de manera que cuando aquí me
toque poner las fuerzas involucradas
aquellas fuerzas que vayan en esta
dirección del movimiento van a ser
positivas y las que vayan en el sentido
opuesto van a ser negativas
qué fuerzas hacen que este sistema se
mueva una de esas fuerzas es la fuerza
de gravedad que se encuentra en esta
masa de 9 kilogramos esta fuerza es la
que hace que se mueva todo el sistema si
yo liberará estas cajas o la soltará
todo el sistema comenzaría a moverse en
esta dirección
debido a esta fuerza de gravedad la
ponemos aquí y va a ser 9 kilogramos por
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
y es positiva porque va en esta
dirección
y no tenemos alguna otra fuerza que haga
que se mueva el sistema así que ahora
vamos a poner aquellas fuerzas que se
resisten a este movimiento bueno una de
estas fuerzas es la fuerza de gravedad
que hay en esta masa de 4 kilogramos
pero no toda la fuerza de gravedad que
tiene aquí está frenando el sistema la
fuerza de gravedad en esta masa de 4
kilogramos va en esta dirección pero
sólo aquel componente que tiene esta
dirección es el que se resiste al
movimiento del sistema y este componente
es m g
por el seno de teta y si esto no les
suena familiar los invito a que vean el
vídeo en donde trabajamos con planos
inclinados y verán que el componente de
la gravedad que va paralelo al plano
inclinado es m por g por el seno de
theta ahora pongo esto aquí en mi
ecuación y va a ser menos
la masa de 4 kilogramos por la gravedad
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado por
el seno del ángulo este es mi ángulo por
el seno de 30 grados
y aquí vamos a necesitar más espacio
porque todavía hay algunas otras fuerzas
que se oponen a este movimiento voy a
mover esto hacia acá tenemos otra fuerza
más que se va a poner a este movimiento
y esta es la fuerza de fricción que
también va a tener esta dirección pero
esta no va a tener la magnitud de m por
g por el seno de theta recuerden la
fórmula de la fricción cinética es f k
igual a muy acá por efe n
esto va a ser igual a moca que es esto
0.2 x fn pero aquí hay que tener cuidado
en este caso fm no es igual a m por g ya
que aquí estamos en un plano inclinado y
la fuerza normal va a ir hacia acá aquí
la fuerza normal no tiene que equilibrar
a toda la fuerza de gravedad cuando se
encuentra en un plano inclinado solo
tiene que equilibrar a que el componente
que es perpendicular al del plano y éste
resulta ser m por g por coseno de teta
ya que este es el componente de la
gravedad en un plano inclinado y si eso
no les parece conocido nuevamente les
recomiendo que vean estos vídeos donde
se habla de los planos inclinados ahí se
explica por qué el componente de la
gravedad en un plano inclinado es m por
g por el coche no detecta y por lo mismo
la fuerza normal es m por g por coseno
de teta ya que no tenemos aceleración en
esta dirección perpendicular a sí
aquí no voy a poner mi fuerza normal
sino solo a que el componente de la
fuerza normal que va en esta dirección y
ese componente es este efe acá esto es
lo que voy a usar que es solamente
aquella parte que se está oponiendo al
movimiento en esta dirección así que
aquí pongo este componente es el que me
interesa y resulta que pues
coincidentemente este componente depende
de la fuerza normal pero bueno lo que
voy a poner aquí es menos
0.2 por la masa que es de 4 kilogramos
gravedad 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
por el coche lo detecta que en este caso
theta es de 30 grados
bien ya tengo todo esto y solamente me
queda dividirlo entre la masa total del
sistema que es 94 van a ser 13
kilogramos
y ustedes me pueden decir a ver un
momento aquí hay otras fuerzas por
ejemplo está la fuerza de tensión que va
hacia acá porque no la estamos usando
bueno resulta que esta es una fuerza
interna y lo atractivo de este truco de
considerar estas masas como un solo
objeto es que podemos ignorar todas
aquellas fuerzas internas aunque tenemos
una fuerza de tensión acá
que va con el movimiento tendremos
también otra fuerza de atención interna
que se opone a este movimiento y estas
dos se van a cancelar así pues estas
fuerzas internas no nos interesan no las
tomamos en cuenta porque se van a
cancelar mutuamente es por esta razón
que usamos este truco de considerar
diferentes objetos como una sola masa
porque con esto todas las fuerzas
internas se van a cancelar y si
calculamos todo esto nos va a dar que es
igual a 4.75 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
esta es la magnitud de la aceleración de
todo el sistema así que esta masa de
cuatro kilogramos se va a acelerar en el
sentido del movimiento del sistema con
una aceleración de 4.75 metros por
segundo al cuadrado esta masa de nueve
kilogramos se va a acelerar hacia abajo
también con una magnitud de aceleración
de 4.75 metros por segundo al cuadrado
ahora si ustedes quisieran conocer cuál
es el valor de alguna de estas tensiones
que finalmente existen solo que no las
tomamos en cuenta cuando usamos la
aproximación de considerar todos los
objetos como una sola masa si ustedes
quisieran conocer cuál es la magnitud de
esta atención que comúnmente es una
segunda pregunta de estos problemas de
sistemas de masas ahora yo sólo
consideraría esta masa de 9 kilogramos
solita vamos a considerarla a ella sola
si yo quisiera encontrar la atención y
las fuerzas en esta masa de 9 kilogramos
escribiría cuál es la aceleración en mi
masa de 9 kilogramos va a ser igual a la
fuerza neta
esta masa de 9 kilogramos dividida entre
la masa de 9 kilogramos ahora ya estoy
considerando solamente esta masa de 9
kilogramos ya terminé de usar esta
aproximación de considerar todos los
objetos en el sistema como uno solo
porque esto es únicamente una forma
rápida de encontrar la aceleración del
sistema y ahora que ya encontré este
valor si quiero encontrar las fuerzas
internas voy a considerar solamente el
objeto de mi interés ahora yo sé que mi
aceleración en esta masa de 9 kilogramos
no es 4.75 sino menos 4.75 metros por
segundo al cuadrado ya que la convención
indica que todo lo que va con dirección
hacia abajo tiene signo negativo por eso
es que le ponemos el signo negativo aquí
esto va a ser igual
son las fuerzas involucradas aquí bueno
si considere que mi aceleración hacia
abajo es negativa la atención que va
hacia arriba va a ser positiva y a esto
le voy a restar la fuerza de gravedad
que va hacia abajo y por eso tiene signo
negativo y es de 9 kilogramos por 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado y lo
divido entre mi masa de 9 kilogramos ya
no estoy considerando la masa total
porque ya terminé de usar esta
aproximación regresamos a considerar
cada uno de los objetos por sí solo y
aplicamos la regla de la segunda ley de
newton de la manera tradicional de
manera que todo lo que va hacia arriba
es positivo todo lo que va hacia abajo
es negativo y sólo me concentro en esta
masa de 9 kilogramos ya no voy a
considerar ninguna de estas otras
fuerzas ya que no tienen nada que ver
con esta masa de 9 kilogramos
si despejo la atención me va a quedar
que este es igual a 45.5 newtons lo que
es menor que 9 por 9.8 lo que tiene
sentido ya que si esta atención fuera
mayor que la gravedad esta masa se
estaría moviendo hacia arriba lo que nos
sucede sabemos que este objeto se mueve
hacia abajo por lo que la fuerza neta
tendrá que tener esta dirección y por lo
tanto esta atención tiene que ser menor
a la fuerza de gravedad en resumen esta
forma de tratar todos los objetos en el
sistema como si fueran uno solo es una
forma muy rápida de obtener la magnitud
de la aceleración del sistema es decir
la magnitud de la aceleración de todos
los objetos en el sistema pero una vez
que encontramos esta magnitud entonces
ya podemos encontrar cualquier fuerza
interna que querramos aplicando la
segunda ley de newton de la manera
tradicional
usamos la segunda ley de newton para
cada objeto individual ya no las
consideramos como una sola masa sino que
las tratamos de forma individual así
podremos encontrar las fuerzas internas
como por ejemplo la fuerza de tensión